so i think this is probably winning two  pawns is i think technically a draw but  there's no way he's gonna have time to  set it up  no and there's also that extra pawn just  in case like i don't know if that  matters  but it could so rookie two game over  king anyone don't take it  don't take it don't take that rook a3  that's that's smart nice try though by  levy that was a very nice try  and don't play rook b2 because that puts  the king on a stalemate so do not play  i don't like that check check yes nice  nice move  these guys are both playing really well  here yeah they really are  one intended you got to go rook b8 or  right side c3 just push that pawn  i think okay only rook check king e3  oh and king c1 just what a wild position  no no what  no that could be stalemate oh my god  dixie  rook takes you too it was a season it  doesn't work anymore  oh what the hell my gosh  what the hell was that